some infection and HBO's The Last of Us
is actually based on this very real
parasitic fungus that turns certain
insects into zombies growing from her
head that is the fruiting body that
contains the spores the creators of the
game and the new show were inspired by
zombie carpenter ants specifically they
even gave the bugs a quick Cameo so it's
a pretty cool Easter egg that's in the
game the zombies in The Last of Us go
through four stages of infection which
have parallels in nature wired spoke to
an expert on the real fungus reference
in The Last of Us those are a lot of
spores to compare those zombies with
similar examples in nature
most zombies and TV and film are
depicted as reanimated corpses but not
in The Last of Us viruses can make us
ill but fungi can alter our very Minds
one thing it does right where a lot of
movies do it wrong is that the infected
are still alive when they're manipulated
there's lots of examples of this in
nature the brains of living crickets
cockroaches and even mammals can get
hijacked by different types of zombie
parasites that alter their behavior new
research shows that gray wolves get
infected with Toxoplasma by interacting
with cougars and their feces which carry
the parasite those that are infected are
more risk-taking more bold becoming the
leader of the pack the behaviors that
we're seeing are rather complex and in
the case of ants the cordyceps parasite
spreads throughout the body as a yeast
which secretes chemicals that behave
similarly to neurotransmitters in the
brain it looks like the fungus is
avoiding the nervous tissue it's not
chewing on it it's not eating it these
cells might be close to the brain and
then secretes molecules that manipulated
in such situated behave so precisely to
help this fungus spread in the first
stage the infected humans don't show
outward signs of their condition in the
beginning the ants don't behave
differently after a few days you see
that the behavior of the ends definitely
is changing in the video game it starts
with a twitch twitching we also see this
in our ants they seem to have sometimes
whole body convulsions the fungus is
producing a compound that is similar to
eflatrim certain fungi produce this and
when an animal ingests this they get
stagger's syndrome so they get these
Tremors then the humans in the last of
us get a little hyper moving at high
speed as if stimulated by chemicals
excreted by the fungus a similar thing
happens with the zombies in Professor to
Becker's lab they're out and about all
times of the day in constant Locomotion
soon The Last of Us Runners lose the
ability to speak so do infected ants in
a sense they don't communicate so well
with other Nest mates anymore ants will
sniff each other out with their entity
the smell of these ants definitely
changed so if an end starts to smell
differently because she is sick they
basically will kill her and put her on a
discard pile there might be a similar
social immunity Dynamic at play in The
Last of Us I see a pile of humans
infected by this fungus and sprouting
mushroom bodies definitely a pile I
wouldn't want to get near you know stage
two the stalker phase of the last of the
zombies is characterized by obvious
fungal growth the stalker definitely
looks more cordyceps like so all those
strings growing off of the head they
very much remind me of the stocks that
we see on our ants for instance it looks
like the first bit of a mushroom body
coming off of the left side of her head
that looks pretty gnarly similarly in
nature the parasitic mesopora fungus
radically transforms its host's physical
shape and gives it a desire to seek out
new hosts to infect this cicada you'll
see
that it's missing a part it's behind its
genitals aptly named the butt fungus
because it loses its butt that's a
fungal plug and the powder are the
fungal spores this is how the fungus is
able to release its spores and infect
other cicada in the game and in the show
has fungus is able to reproduce by
biting other humans or by contact with
spores off of other humans that have
these fruiting bodies sprouting off of
them misospera resembles the fungus in
the game a little bit because in the
last of us and in nature zombies have
increased energy and they start to
spread out and wander normally these
ants would go forged for food with their
nest mates and nicely follow and trails
instead they actually just wander around
aimlessly could a similar wandering
Dynamic be at play with gray wolves
infected with a protozoan parasite
wolves infected with Toxoplasma are more
likely to wander away from their former
pack to find a new one and are more
risk-taking more bold the Wolves studied
recently in Yellowstone National Park
could be drifting nearer to the source
of their infection cougars because
Toxoplasma reproduces only in the
stomach of felines in The Last of Us
during the clicker phase the fungus has
really taken over
in the clicker the morphologies changed
entirely so it makes me think more of
the fungus called chicken of the woods
which is an edible fungus at this point
the zombies rely on echolocation after
losing their sight in real life zombie
ants might also become impaired because
they start randomly climbing towards
light they will climb up a plant at
certain light levels because they don't
perceive light so well anymore and
they're trying to search for it or
they're getting themselves off the
ground this is what we call summiting
Behavior something that a lot of
parasites have evolved to use as a
strategy to transmit better the fungus
is making the end find some sort of
micro climate that helps the fungus to
develop its mushroom that releases the
spores but if you're higher up in the
air then your spores can be more easily
carried by the wind and can land on or
be eaten by a new host another example
of infected hosts acting in the interest
of their parasite are cockroaches that
get stung by Jewel wasp which inject
their victims with a kind of mind
control Venom along with a brood of eggs
this changes the behavior of the
Cockroach entirely doesn't want to fight
anymore it's this very docile creature
that then follows the WASP back to its
burrow if he gets eaten alive by it is
developing egg that eventually becomes a
larva and not a situation that is
beneficial to this cockroach but very
beneficial to The Offspring of the WASP
similarly crickets infected by the
gordian worm are compelled to act
self-destructively the worm needs to be
in water to mate so what this worm does
is it makes these crickets jump into
water this Cricket has no business being
in the water so basically they have
committed suicide and now the worm can
breed in its natural habitat the water a
similar process happens with Toxoplasma
in mice which breeds in the digestive
system of cats rodents that get infected
with toxoplasmosis actually makes these
rodents attracted to cat urine it's
making it more likely that this rodent
will get eaten definitely behavior that
is beneficial to Toxoplasma but
absolutely not for the rodent in the
last of this game it takes years for the
fungus to cover the skin completely and
turn human into slow-moving bloater but
for zombie ants in real life to succumb
completely takes about three weeks and
the beginning of the end starts with a
hyper contraction of the jaw muscles and
spider Branch can't let go and die as
they're eaten by the fungus within when
the ant is in place the fungus quickly
changes its strategy and starts to eat
everything including the brain to
produce a fruiting body this is when the
fungus will change from being a yeast to
forming a mycelium everything inside is
just mycelium bursting out of the host
so this is what we often call the stock
you see that on that stock there's this
brown bulbous thing attached that's the
fooding body so that carries the spores
those are all mushrooms if you will
those are all fruiting bodies as the
Spore gets into the air and as the air
moves it can easily take it to different
places so this is why we think that this
summiting behavior is actually helping
the fungus to spread its spores see this
Spore Cloud those are a lot of spores
this one would be exuding spores like
crazy looks you know very similar to
what we envision the spores would look
like they're microscopically small so we
can hardly see them but people that
recorded spores coming from mushrooms
that's kind of what it looks like
according to a recent World Health
Organization report fungal infections
are estimated to kill at least 1.6
million people yearly aspergillus
fumigatas can even spread to the brain
of the immunocompromised other fungal
pathogens are even showing resistance in
settings like hospitals should we be
worried most of the fungi that we know
of at least they like to grow at the
lower temperatures than our body
temperature our bodies are just not
great hosts to infect because the
temperature would be too high however in
climate change and the Earth getting
warmer fungi need to adapt to be able to
grow at higher temperatures as well
their optimal temperature will become
closer to our body temperature making it
more likely that in the future we'll
have more fungal infections yikes but
there is one reason why all of humanity
isn't likely to be wiped out by a mutant
zombie fungus apocalypse like in The
Last of Us in the game and in this show
what you see is that humanity is on the
brink of being extinct there and aren't
that many humans left that's actually
not a very smart strategy if you wipe
out your host entirely then eventually
there's no hosts to infect so it will
stop to exist as well there's so much
more going on that we don't understand
quite yet we also interact with a lot of
microbes and a lot of organisms that are
beneficial to us our microbiome has
influence on a lot of our physiology
then leads to certain behaviors so who
would we be without our parasites who
would be being with other microbes I
think it's a very interesting
philosophical question